for years hillary rodham clinton has
told people that she was named for the
first man to climb mount everest sir
edmund hillary
but as esquire magazine recently pointed
out sir edmund did not climb mount
everest until 1953
six years after hillary was born however
the first lady does have a good
explanation for the discrepancy
she loves to lie
yeah joe biden what a kook i can't wait
till he meets greta thunberg can we get
those two
together you know have him creep out on
her you know he hugs her for too long
he's like is it global warming or is it
hot in here
she's like how dare you
george w bush jr the w stands for where
the hell
is it
you know you look at george w and you
realize some men are born great
some achieve greatness and some get it
as a graduation gift
so sad
[Music]
[Applause]
a lot of people don't realize there's a
lot of similarities between
america and russia you know we're not
that different right
you like russian brides we like russian
brides you know
you like bombing syria you know
it's fun isn't it fun you know
putin controls your country putin you
know
says when the prime minister of the
country that you live in
breaks off from the g20 summit he's in a
meeting with obama the most important
man in the world he says excuse me obama
i need a minute here something very
important i need to deal with right now
jimmy carter dick
[ __ ] off but there's a reason for that
because it matters more for that matters
more black people see
so even when i vote right which i don't
but but
but even when i like think about like
who i would vote for
right i don't even look at their
political policies
i just look at their character
you know what i'm saying now you got to
renault i'm serious you got to read
between the lines like you know you look
at clinton and black people like clinton
because we've seen him on the campaign
that's all one thing on the campaign
trail he he actually just picked the
black baby up and kicked him come here
little [ __ ] baby
[Music]
i like that he did not hesitate or
nothing
you see george bush junior
like say i'd never vote for george bush
junior but i don't know george was doing
his politics
the only thing i know about george bush
jr is that that guy
sniffed cocaine that's right now listen
we cannot
have that shooting the white house that
might be fine for a mayor
but god dammit not no idea
the states are too high in the white
house can't have no coke head president
he'd be selling nuclear seekers for 20
30 and [ __ ]
could be in meetings embarrassing
america come on
sign the treaty baby i suck your dick
like what
and of course it was very inspiring to
see president clinton up here on
crutches making a speech i mean
i thought that was just amazing you know
i mean it's been difficult for the
president you know he can't jog
now and he needs help getting around and
he's still you know he still
uh occasionally suffers great pain you
know
on the upside you got your medical
marijuana so that's uh
you must inhale sir it's the only way
you're going to get better
it's
somebody asked me earlier too they say
gabriel when you get to do your special
are you going to do anything about the
country you're going to talk about
politics
well i'm going to talk about first of
all how i love this country and i
wouldn't want to live anywhere else i
know that half the
world right now thinks that our leader
is the devil and most of us would agree
he's not uh
i don't have to make fun of the
president he does it by himself
okay he does hit him by himself
every time he comes on tv i can't wait
to hear what he has to say
especially during press conferences
right mr president question
it's been over a year what is your plan
for katrina
we're gonna find her
that's right and we're gonna bring
katrina to justice
we have every reason to believe katrina
is connected to al qaeda
k to katrina they both start with a k
our president got elected i didn't vote
for him but then again i didn't vote for
the other guy either i was just like
how bush one is beyond me americans we
love to vote but we don't vote for
presidents
we vote for things like american idol
because that's fun voting for presidents
is not fun voting for american history
that's what they should do for
presidents you know just put both guys
on tv for one hour call it something
catchy like who's gonna run this [ __ ]
you put him on tv for an hour let him
argue 30 minutes into the special you
put a 800 number on the screen and say
cast your vote right
you've reached the presidential hotline
for george bush
press three john kerry press four other
options press
five you don't like either one press
five
please hold
[Music]
i knew you'd be back
that's right you know you miss your
daddy
trump told his chief of staff and i
quote
hitler did a lot of good things
[Music]
[Applause]
now to be fair we don't know which
hitler trunk was talking about
could have been steve hitler guillermo
was there steve hitler i don't think so
i don't think so either come on hitler
did a lot of good things
hitler only did one good thing he killed
hitler
so this is interesting according to new
research counties that voted for trump
have lower vaccination rates eighty
percent of democrats have received
at least one shot of a vaccine only 45
percent of republicans have had one shot
you know for a party that claims to be
pro-life
they're acting very pro-death
[Applause]
you lived here in new york for a while
yes i did uh did you pay attention to
the election we got a new mayor here
bloomberg
i didn't even know there was an election
i honestly don't i don't pay attention
at all i
i you know it's bankers get bonuses of
anywhere
the upper echelon get from like 10
million up to 100 million
and the president of the united states
makes like 400 grand a year
so right there i watched enough
wrestling to see a rigged game
you know it's like people with youtube
channels making as much
as the leader of the free world so i
just think he's set up to be bribed
and uh you act accordingly so any
basically anybody who comes at me going
these these uh you know the conservative
right or you know
these liberals like i just zone out i
can't even talk to you if you're
actually still looking at it
like those are two choices you're not
it's the same
once you get past a certain level it
just seems like it's it's all the same
yeah you've jumped in the river
and you act accordingly or you get that
convertible ride in dallas
so are we still excited about barack
obama
[Applause]
see every black person in here should be
clapping
because we got to ride that [ __ ] till
the wheels fall off
you know if that [ __ ] don't work the
minute we go to work white folks is
looking at us like
hmm you picked him
i can't wait till he runs for his second
term man because that was the most
exciting part about the political
process to me was the campaign
because you knew at some point he was
supposed to win he had all the right
ingredients that came together at the
right time
he's tall good looking articulate highly
intelligent
you know smooth under pressure
charismatic and most importantly
he was the right shade
he made white people feel comfortable
because y'all know if that [ __ ] was
bernie mac black
or precious purple he wouldn't want he's
like coffee with cream it goes down easy
you ever have coffee black it's too
strong you're like oh
america is not ready for ooh they're not
ready yet
and he had 97 of the black vote 97
which means he had black people online
we were like a hand and a glove we were
tied together
but he still couldn't become president
without white people so for the white
people that voted for him
i thank you because you helped make
history
[Applause]
but some of y'all are starting to get a
little impatient and your racism is
seeping out a little bit
you say [ __ ] when you're frustrated i
thought you [ __ ] were fast what's
taking so long
it took eight years to [ __ ] this country
up it's gonna take a second to get it
together relax
you got a lot of tough [ __ ] you gotta
deal with man like the big controversy
right now they talking about that mosque
near september 11th a lot of people
upset about that
you know september 11 just rolled around
every year we got to relive that
[ __ ]
but there was a bright side man you know
september 11 blacks and whites came
together like never before
because after september 11 arabs took
all the pressure off us
i'm telling you they are the new [ __ ]
that's amazing
i get on a plane now white people y'all
be happy to see us dude bro come here
here sit next to me man right here here
hold my daughter
i love you [ __ ] come here we gotta
watch out for those [ __ ] for chisel
nizzle
huh we've bonded now that's good
and i realized certain aspects of that
[ __ ] just affected people differently
like when the anthrax thing happened
white people y'all was very nervous
y'all would come up to me at work and
warn me like oh my god
that's how white people get when they
get dramatic oh my god
aries be careful don't open your mail
okay some black people was never worried
about anthrax
because y'all don't have this hand we
don't open up mail no way
we think that [ __ ] is a bill we might
hold it to the light like no that's the
red notes
[ __ ] that you want to get us with
anthrax put this [ __ ] in the jz cd
that's how you get up
i got that new [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
osama got me [ __ ] track 12
[ __ ] be careful track 12.